في هذه الحاله كان هناك عروس وعريس يريدان
ان يكرم امهما وهنا هناك خلط في اذهان
الناس كنت استمع الى احاديث الجماعه كلمه
العرف تكررت والتربيه والعادات العادات
ليست مقدسه العدد هي اشياء يمكن ان نفكر
فيها وان نراجعها والدليل اننا في البلدان
العربيه الاسلاميه تقريبا جميعا لنا قدس
خاصه للام الجنه تحت اقدام الامهات نحب
الامهات ندعو الى كسبناهم ولكن عندما
يتعلق الامر بحفل الزواج وعقمه عقد الزواج
تتاخر الام
ويتقدم الاب همم
اشكال في عقود فيها الاب يكون شاهدا لكن
هنا العروسين هما نفسهما يعني الرجل
والمراه ابنتي وزوجها رغبه في ان تكون
الشاهده هي الام هذا الشخص هي راعهم واهتم
به الى اخره ليس هناك اي شيء يمنع قانونيا
ولا حتى شرع لانه في الشرع المعاملات
الماليه هي التي فيها مشكله رجل رجل
وامراتان وما الى ذلك وفيها اجتهادات
متعدده ليس هذا مجال